so far we've learned a little bit about
determining electron configurations
let's see if we can use that information
to group elements on the periodic table
and then guess as to what they might do
when they react with other elements so
let's just figure out the electron
configurations and of a couple of
elements just for a little bit of
practice so lithium right there what
does it look like lithium's electron
configuration you get the first shell is
1s 2 2 electrons there and then you have
2 s1 and sometimes just to be quick to
get the notation as you can imagine
lithium's electron configuration is the
exact same thing as helium's electron
configuration this is helium's electron
configuration
plus the 2s 1 so this could have also
been written as do it in light blue
could have written been written as
helium 2 s1 which essentially means that
lithium's electron configuration is
exactly what you would have written for
helium's electron configuration and then
you have written to s1 you could do that
a bunch of times let's see if we wanted
to figure out the electron configuration
of iron instead of going through the
whole thing you know it's 1s 2 and then
it's 2's 2 and 2 P 6 instead of doing
that whole thing you could just say okay
iron has the same an electron
configuration so you could say right
irons electron configuration is the same
thing as Argon's it is the same thing as
our gonzo electron configuration so I'll
just put argon in brackets and then you
get to do what it says for s2 for s2 and
then you have 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 so d6 and we
learned when you're in the in the D sub
shell or when you're in the D block of
the periodic table you are actually
adding your backfilling the previous
shell so we're we're in the fourth
period in the d block we're back filling
the third shell so 3 d6 and someone had
asked and this is an interesting
question why does it do that
why does it not just continue why
doesn't it fill the fourth D shell and
the way I think about it and this is all
intuition and things that the atomic
level really start to become on some
levels not intuitive by the way I think
about it as the atom grows larger and
larger there are more spaces between the
previous orbitals for example and this
is kind of just a you know this is just
how I visualize it is as if you know my
first shell looks like this let's say
the s looks like this and then if I just
cut it out let's say the peas look like
something like this let's say the peas
look like this this is maybe in the
second shell the peas look like this and
then the next place that electron might
want to be might be in the third shell
right so the third shell would be like
this
and then you fill out the third piece
shell and how do you know it's I'm just
this is just an intuition this is an
exactly what electron look like maybe
the third pea shell it looks something
like that
looks something like that and then looks
something like that and then you're in
the fourth shell so you're doing you
know the fourth shell you might be the s
subshell might look something like that
and then instead of immediately starting
the next piece shell you're in the
d-block now so this might be so this is
you know let me just write some labels
so this is this is for s this is three s
this is three P this is two P this is 2
s 2 s in there and then 1 s is inside of
2 s you don't have to worry about that
too much but my intuition behind why the
D orbital gets back filled is because
now as the atom gets larger and larger
you have these spaces in between the
previous orbitals so now after filling
after filling the 4 s sub shell or the
4s orbital so this is 4 s here after
filling this out here we go back and we
fill in the 3 D orbitals so we're going
I can run filling these spaces right
here so this is a lower energy state
than this it takes more energy to cram
an electron back into the 3d shell back
there but then once you do that now
you're ready to then add back you go to
the 4p shell which might look something
like which might look something like
this so the electron would rather go to
another shell which is the fourth shell
rather than backfill the three the 3d
shell oh sorry the 3d shells but once it
fills out the fourth shell then it fills
in those spaces in between and as the
electron gets bigger and bigger there's
more and more spaces in between so
eventually when the electron gets big
enough there's going to be spaces
between the D shells and that's where
the F sub shells or the the D orbitals
and that's where the F orbitals will go
that's my intuition behind it's working
and obviously when we're dealing at the
atomic scale as far as I'm concerned
that's the best that I can do but fair
enough that's not what I wanted to do
here but that was a good question as to
you know why do you go and backfill the
third shell when we're in the fourth
period fair enough this is an easy way
to write to write irons electron
configuration the reason why I'm doing
all of this is to just figure out how
many electrons you have in the outermost
shell in the case of lithium you have
one electron in your outermost shell
right this is your outermost shell right
here you have one electron and you could
have done the same thing right there in
the case of iron how many electrons in
the outermost shell
remember the outermost shell is the
period you're in and this is the
outermost shell so even though these are
higher energy electrons it took more
energy to backfill those into the lower
energy shell it's these that are on the
outside energy shell the fourth shell
that are going to be the ones that are
reacting and how many are there they're
two and this is an important thing so
there's two here there's two on the
outside shell here and actually there's
going to be two for any of these in pink
right here any of the ones in the
d-block what happens you go you fill
whatever period you're in let's say
you're in period five here right you're
going to 5s one 5s - and then you're
going to go back and you're going to
fill the 4d
she'll write but in terms of how many
electrons you have on the outside shell
in this case the fifth shell you're
going to have two electrons so all of
these are going to have two electrons in
their outermost shell in the case of
these the outermost electrons are going
to be for s2 right because then you go
back and fill the 3d but the outer ones
are for s2 so this one also has two
electrons in its outermost shell how
many does this group have and I've just
used a word that I don't know if I have
defined before but the groups are the
columns in the periodic table and as you
can see they all have kind of patterns
to them that everything in this first
group has one electron in its outermost
shell if you don't believe me look at
hydrogen what's the hydrogen's electron
configuration is 1s one its outermost
shell is 1s it has one electron there
right and that's true for all of these
all of these guys have two electrons in
their outermost shell these guys have
those same two electrons we can view it
that way in their outermost shell but
then they go and backfill the D shell
but if in terms of their outermost shell
only two electrons then once you fill
the d-block or you go backfill you know
in the case of the fourth period you go
in backfill the the third D sub orbital
then you go back to filling the fourth
shell again now the p-block right so
this one's going to have three three
electrons and it's outside orbital or
you could say three valence electrons
this is four five six seven and eight
let me do one more just in case you
don't believe me
what's the electron configuration for oh
I don't know what is SN this is what
selenium I think I'm not even sure but
let's say SN what's the electron
configuration it's going to have the
same electron configuration as Krypton
yes that element is Krypton there is
such an element so they'll have the same
electron configuration as Krypton so I
could have figured out Krypton's
electron configuration just by going
through the whole periodic table but
there's just a faster way of doing it
same thing as Krypton and
it has 5s to 5s to then it goes back and
back fills the d-block so and there's 10
there so for D 10 for D 10 and then it
starts filling up the p-block and the
fifth shell again so v p2 v p2 so how
many valence electrons does it have
we're valence electrons or electrons in
the outermost shell well what's the
outermost shell is the fifth shell so
it's DS and these these are these
electrons have a higher energy state
than that it would took a little bit
more energy to cram them back into that
previous shell than it took to put these
on the the S orbital but if you talk
about the electrons that will react and
that's why I'm emphasizing these these
are the electrons that are going to
react with other other atoms or
sometimes with just kind of the other
electrons even this one has four outside
electrons then you see that right there
four outside electrons and since the
outside electrons are for the most part
the ones that you're going to care about
there's a uu there's a I guess you could
say a notation where you only draw the
outermost electrons so let's say for
hydrogen you could write it like this
we're only drawing the outermost valence
electrons valence electrons are just the
outermost electrons you could write like
that you could write it like that but
this says hey I just have one outside
electron for hydrogen if I wanted to
draw it for iron iron right here how
would I do that I have two electrons in
my outermost shell so iron I could just
do like this and electrons they tend to
be paired so you you you you know if I
have let's say I wanted to take the
example of if this is SN this is
selenium let me do carbon carbon I have
four electrons in my outermost shell so
carbon I could write like this carbon I
could write like that or if I didn't
want to pair them I didn't want to pair
them in theory I could write them like
that as well and now they're ready to
react with other things now what does
this tell me about you know
one has one electron in its outermost
shell this one these blue these noble
gases and we'll talk a little bit about
them in a second these have eight
electrons in the outermost shell how
does that help me when I'm actually
trying to figure out how things react
well it turns out that all atoms want to
have eight electrons in their outermost
shell and that number is important eight
they want to have eight eight electrons
in their outermost shell this is the
most stable configuration for atoms this
or I guess you could say in to some
degree a better energy state for the
atom and why is it the number eight well
that's something to think about this is
just another this is another kind of
fundamental number that just pops out of
nature and I thought a little bit about
it it must be something about the atoms
it went you know on the outermost shell
when you have eight they resonate well
with each other and they they I don't
know they and somehow don't get in the
way or each other or don't want to push
away from each other I don't know the
answer to that and frankly if someone
could really answer the question of why
why eight exactly why eight did you know
maybe that's that they make a good
career for themselves in physics or
chemistry but through experimentation it
has been well established that atoms
want to have eight electrons in their
outermost shell so the question is if
you're dealing with something like let's
say you're dealing with potassium right
potassium has one electron in its
outermost shell and then you have stuff
like let's say you have stuff like
chlorine chlorine that has seven
electrons in its outermost shell what do
you think is going to happen if you put
some potassium in near some chlorine
what's going to happen well what's the
easiest way for the chlorine to get to
get to the to get eight electrons well
it has seven in its outermost shell
what's the easiest way to look it'll
want to gain an electron really really
badly and what's the easiest way for
potassium to have eight electrons in its
outermost shell well if it lost that one
electron then it will have eight
electrons in its outermost shell right
its outermost shell won't be the fourth
shell anymore it'll be the third shell
but it'll have eight electrons in the
third shell its configuration will then
look like argon if it loses that that
one electron so until it'll be you know
kind of a more stable state so if you
put sodium in the presence of chlorine
what's going to happen this electron
wants to jump off of sodium real bad so
that sodium can have eight electrons in
its outermost shell or have an electron
configuration like argon and that
electron is going to jump to chlorine
and then chlorine will have eight
electrons in its outermost shell and
also have electron configuration like
argon and so is you can imagine these
things this group right here which are
called the alkali metals alkali metals
and we'll talk probably the next video
why they're called metals this group
here alkali metals and they tend to
exclude hydrogen and we'll talk about
that and these really want to give away
electrons and because of that they're
highly highly reactive especially if you
put them in the presence of these
elements these yellow elements right
here which are called the halogens these
really really want to take electrons
from other things because they just need
one to get to eight these really want to
give away electrons because they just
have to give away one to get to eight
and the reason why I hydrogen actually
isn't included is because hydrogen
doesn't want to give away its electron
as bad as these guys hydrogen this eight
this rule that your outer most shell
wants to get to eight that's true for
everything except for hydrogen and
helium hydrogen helium just because they
have one shell they're happy with just
two electrons and so with hydrogen sure
it could loot it could lose an electron
but can just easily gain an electron and
be happy because it'll have a full first
shell but all of these other ones these
alkali metals they want to give away
electrons really bad when people in
chemistry talk about metallic nature
they're really talking about how badly
something wants to get wants to give
away electrons anyway I'm all out of
time now in the next video we'll
continue discussing the groups in the
periodic tables and any trends we can
ascertain from them